Hey, what's going on is bill burn is
time for them. Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and yeah,
just checking in on you. Just checking
in on you, seen how your week's going.
How's your week going?
Hard.
Did your fucking team have another
championship parade? Like minded? Well,
you know what? I wish
it did. Why of function?
My town have all the goddamn success.
You know,
it's fucking unbelievable. I still
can't believe the one that fucking game,
but I'm not going to go.
Yeah.
One and on and on and on and on and
on and on and on and on and on. Right.
Um, I'm in Charlotte, North Carolina came
in and day before the comedy zone Gig.
I went to the, uh, shall at horn.
It's versus the Brooklyn Nets,
you know, and when you try to go to
a home game, sorry, I'm going to,
I don't have my fucking microphone,
so I'm just recording. Right.
If my laptop's on, anytime I click on
something might be goddamn issue. Um,
but, uh, when you're trying to do
what it is that I've been doing,
which is to basically go to all of the,
uh,
to go to a home game of every fucking
team and all four major sports,
every once in a while you got to go
to a game. It's not the best game.
You've got to go see a couple of
franchises dead. Even though they,
they've had their moments, this
is not their time. They are,
are currently re rebuilding and that,
so that's what happened when we saw the
Charlotte Hornets play the Brooklyn Nets.
Um, a couple of nights ago, Jesus Christ,
it was, it was just like it was,
I dunno, I dunno what it was.
It was like a fucking WNB game.
WNB At its worst in the first couple
of seasons, you know, where they,
they just didn't look good to me.
They look way better now,
the fundamentals and all that,
if you watch any,
the WNB but those first few years I
couldn't understand why it looks so bad
cause women's college basketball look
better in a WNB. But Jesus Christ,
Charlotte, first, Brooklyn, Jewish,
Jewish, and I say that enough time,
oh this is how fucking
boring that game was.
The kids that played at halftime was
fucking more exciting cause they will run
in the court. Big smiles on their
faces was fucking hilarious.
The game was like subdued,
like you know, 16 to 14.
And it was all lay ups.
It was just all fucking run in the court.
Lay ups was tremendous.
And um, but anyways,
last night, uh, we went to, um, you know,
we worked the comedy zone and uh,
I did the smartest thing I've ever done
on the road in a long time was when the
show was over. I just went home
and I went to fucking bed. Um,
because the Charlotte Brooklyn night,
you know, I had a couple of flops,
about 17 and a. The next day
woke up. I'm like, what? What
the, what am I doing? Okay,
what the fuck am I doing? Okay,
I've got a newborn at home.
I can't get any God sleep. I'm on
the road now. I should be like a,
a fucking sober as a church mouse.
And just go right to bed.
And that's what I did last night.
Fucking phenomenal.
Other than God damn fucking cleaning
ladies coming by every 10 minutes.
Yeah.
Yeah. They didn't, they play some stain
and doesn't have the fuck off side.
Um, so they just keep
coming. Housekeeping.
I love when they fucking knock,
right housekeeping and then immediately
open the Goddamn door. There's that.
There's the lost art
of knocking on a door,
waiting for a response and then
coming in somewhere along the line.
These goddamn kids today. Oh yeah. I
just said that these God damn kids,
they think the fact they just
knocked that they can just,
w means they can then enter the room.
You knock, you wait for somebody to say,
you know, hang on a second or
blah blah, blah, blah, blah.
You don't just knock on a
fucking door and walk in.
You got to give the person a chance, you
know, put the dick away of something,
you know. Well, who
knows what they're doing.
Maybe they're just sitting
there in their underwear, right.
I don't fucking know. She fucking knock.
And you wait and then you went to,
sorry,
I'm just saying it fucking can't stand.
That's one of my pet peeves in life.
People who knock and then
they just fucking walk in.
Um, that shit. Or if you know,
when you go into to a parking spot,
you know with two cars could fit and you
just stick your fucking cunt car right
in the middle of both.
So no one can fit two cars can't fit
anymore unless you're driving a smart car.
Um, so anyways, tonight you probably
thinking, Jesus, Bill, I have to,
uh,
they're patriots super bowl.
Okay.
How could your sport,
I could just sportsworld get any better.
You know what I mean? Well, after, uh, uh,
a major dip I believe on Monday,
which I think they,
they did on purpose cause the Bruins had
a little gap in their schedule with all
the buzz about it. The patriots
excuse, we have yard already care.
Be a good time to get rid
of, uh, quote Julian. And uh,
I just want to thank coach Julian for,
uh,
being the best Bruins coach since
I've been watching them. Um,
for the last, you know,
close to 40 years. Um,
chasesL is Farzeen everybody.
[inaudible] I'm doing my podcast.
All right.
Do you think or no? Uh, just the Thursday
one. I'll be done like a half hour.
All right, cool. Hey Paul,
you go eat those eggs and then I'll
meet your first team. All right.
We got breakfast coming in and like 20.
When it's done, I'll call you. Okay. Okay,
pal. Okay. All right. The acuity
anyways.
Um,
okay.
The fuck. What the fuck was I talking
about? Yeah. [inaudible] Julian,
Jesus Christ. I'd never seen a guy
more of a victim of the GM and for the,
I do not that fucking move whatsoever.
You know, I guess maybe if he had a
fallen out with the people up top,
I have no idea. But, um, how,
how you just going to blame it on him
and not get rid of your fucking GM?
I don't know what they see in this.
Our GM, I have no fucking idea.
I don't know. Uh, I have no
idea what this guy's doing.
I mean he got rid of everybody and
I just didn't, I don't see they,
we actually were playing our best
hockey of the year. I felt, you know,
we won three in a row. Lost a tough one
of the fucking capital's not a tough one.
They actually kicked our ass five to two.
But I mean what the fuck?
They're the capitals. We didn't do
bad for a seven seat. I don't know.
I think it's a dumb move.
You get rid of the guys like okay,
you want to get rid of the guy? Who are
you to replace them with? WHO's out there?
You know, and it actually tweeted
congratulations to every year,
every other NHL team out there that needs
a fucking coach that knows how to win
a cup. Um, cause that's
what we just dumped.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't get to ship that stuff where
the ownership gives into the fan base.
It's like what are they listening to?
The fucking Dope said.
Call into sports talk radio.
I've never called it a sports talk.
I watch sports all the fucking time.
I would never call it a sports
talk radio show, you know,
just specifically to talk
about the sports thing. I mean,
I'll call it into hyper show,
you know, whore myself out. Oh,
I would absolutely do that.
I was speaking of whoring myself out.
Um, well wait, wait, wait,
wait. Let me get it back. So,
uh, thank you. Hello Julian.
And uh, for bringing us the
Stanley Cup and uh, and in, uh,
you know, 40 year drought, um,
and continued success wherever you go.
I know you're going to
do great wherever you go.
Hopefully you got a better GM at
the next place you'd go up to. Um,
so anyways,
um,
after all my ranting and
raving about a award shows,
I think I might be a presenter at one.
All Hollywood bill is the
a writer's guild awards.
And um, they asked me to be a presenter
or whatever. And at first I was like, Nah,
I'm not going to go down and do that
fucking bullshit. But then, you know what,
I'm actually, I guess soften
enough or selling out,
depends on how you look at it.
But what I realize is that on our show,
um, it's those award shows
are a big deal for, uh,
for the writers because that's
how they actually get money.
So if you win an Emmy,
um,
or a writer's guild or
sag thing or whatever,
it's great for the writers in the
writer's room cause they can say that they
wrote on an Emmy award winning show
and Blah, blah, blah, blah blah.
So old freckles has to play
the game a little bit. Um,
go put on a God damn monkey suit. It's
a fucking black tie thing. I got to go,
I'm going to go to one of those fucking
from places where they had the cheap
tuxedos cause I don't think
anybody can fucking tell,
just come out in those God
damn plastic bowling shoes. Um,
I know who the fuck decided that they
wanted me to be a fucking presenter,
but like if they've never,
they've obviously never listened
to me read out loud on a,
on my podcast. But, uh, I don't know.
I figured this would be a good one to
try out to see what I, to think about it.
Because a, it's not televised, you know?
And um,
I don't know if we'll see if I can
actually read out loud. I Dunno.
Knee has been on me about the shit. You
got gotta do it. You can't play in a game.
All right.
I'm playing the fucking game.
Why make a fucking difficult business
even more? God damn difficult. Um,
so fuck it. I'll give it, I'll
let you guys know how that goes.
How am I reading out loud, if that's
in fact what they have? Me Too,
but it's not bad. It's only
like two hours long. Um,
so it kind of seems like the best one
to go to and Patton Oswald is hosting it
and I think he's a fucking genius.
So at least I'll get to
listen to his monologue, um,
that I am without a doubt.
I'm going to get the fuck.
I'm going to get a nice fucking,
I'm going to get a senior prom special,
the clip on fucking tie
and all of that shit.
That's like the dumbest shit ever to go
out and go buy some expensive Tuxedo.
It's like, what are you a
fucking Rockefeller? Uh,
but I guess people trashed you then,
right when you've watched walk the
red carpet or something like that. Um,
so anyways,
so there you go.
There's my full of shit
moment after making fun of
all those fucking award shows.
Uh, I'm actually going to
work. Go to one. I don't know.
What are you going to do the
fuck am I going to do right?
I'm doing it for the tape keg.
Can I get out of it by saying that?
So anyways, I was saying,
um, how my, um, my,
uh, my sporting world, how it
could get any better after the, uh,
the Patriots win and then they, uh, the,
the let down of seeing them give into the
fan pressure or whatever the fuck they
did. Get rid of coach Julian. Um,
tonight be frizzy and,
uh,
Joe Barnick or doing a bucket list thing
for any person that's even remotely
into sports. We're going to
the, uh, the Duke versus, uh,
North Carolina Tarheels game tonight,
and we've got some great seats.
Was sitting right behind
the fucking dude bench.
Coach K is going to be there if it
wasn't so God damn loud in that place,
we could hear him, you know, during
the time outs and everything,
it's going to be crazy. So, uh, I dunno,
it was a chance you might see the three,
three of us dummies on TV.
Um,
but beyond excited to go to this like
this is, this is a fucking huge one.
This is a huge one.
Um,
as far as the bucket list sports
stuff to go two years ago I told you,
I don't know if I told you guys
I went to the, um, I went to a
okay.
Indiana university
versus, um, what was it?
Michigan state and I believe it was
the year that Michigan State won the
National Championship and Bobby Knight
was still coaching there and um,
okay.
I've never seen anything like that.
All the years, everything I've ever,
every sporting event I've ever gone to,
I have never seen anything like
watching Bobby Knight coach a game.
I mean, that guy, you watched him as much,
if not more than you
were watching the game.
I was actually rooting for the Spartans.
You know,
I came there rooting for Indiana,
but Bobby was so fucking entertaining.
I started rooting for the Spartans
because I wanted to see him flip out even
more. I've never seen
somebody, yeah, yeah.
She made me feel good about myself,
like just complete loss of composure
obviously, or whatever his
coaching style motivating people.
I remember they let up a couple
of easy buckets and this kid,
the point guard starts bringing it up to
court and Bobby Knight is like 10 feet
onto the court and he's yelling so much.
He's like juicy.
Uh, was it Ben Kingsley and
sexy base? When he, when he's,
when he's yelling,
it'd be in a right content and he's like
thrown his head into everything that
he's saying.
That's what the fuck he was doing.
But it was way more intense because
he wasn't acting. He was serious.
And um, I've never fucking
seen anything like that.
And that's one of my favorite of
everything that I've seen in sports.
The coolest thing ever is that I got
to see Bobby Knight Coach at Indiana
University. Man, that's fucking legendary.
Like scenes Zeplin or seeing the Beatles,
you know,
James Brown or whatever.
Like you know that's right up there.
I saw Eddie Murphy on the Rod tour.
I saw [inaudible]. He's my brother.
Think greatest things I've seen
Eddie Murphy on the raw tour.
I saw when he went to purple suit,
I saw Bobby Knight Coach at Indiana.
MMM.
The fuck did I go from there?
So Judas Priest and the Turbo Lover Tour,
does that count?
I know I saw Stevie Ray Vaughan.
MMM.
I saw Dan Marino kick the
shit out of the Patriots.
MMM.
With Don Shula coaching. That's
the one great thing. Yeah,
it will be in an old guys.
You can start talking about all
this shit since I can note that now.
Fucking no longer exists.
So I actually made a few guys who just
bear with me clicking here. Sorry.
I know it's fucking loud as hell.
I know.
It's annoying and you're going to
listen to it again right now. All right.
I actually looked through,
um,
I got this,
this document teams scene
and um,
yeah,
I have seen 31
I been to a home game.
If every major league baseball team,
I haven't been to all the stadiums
cause like the mets changed.
There's got a new one.
Philly's got a new one. Um,
but I've seen a total of 31.
There's 30 professional baseball teams.
I've seen 31 cause I went to the expos.
Um, I've seen 32 home games
of the NFL. There's 32 teams,
but I still need to see the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers there.
The last one I need to see, but I saw
the Saint Louis and the fucking, um,
the Saint Louis and the
fucking, uh, La Rams.
So that's how I got up to 32.
I've seen 25 NBA teams.
Uh,
one of those being the a,
I saw both the Seattle Sonics and the,
uh,
Oklahoma City Thunder.
Um,
and I saw the New Jersey Nets. Now I got
to go see the fucking Brooklyn that's
speaking of which I also saw the fucking,
oh,
I see the fucking, the islanders at
Nassau Coliseum. Now if they don't,
if they don't become the Brooklyn
fucking islanders,
then uh,
then I don't need to go see him.
It's like if you change your food
that they're still in New York.
You know what I mean? I don't need
to fucking do that. So I've seen 27
of the 30 fucking, uh, I
got three more to see in,
um, in hockey. So I'm going to try to
knock those out over the next year.
The Fan Slam is what I'm
calling it, you know, you know,
Serena's fucking the Serena Slam.
This is just the fence slam the fucking,
you know, you have no life.
You run the fucking road.
You don't want to kill
yourself in a comedy condo.
So you start building it
around home games. Um, back,
she made a list and I don't
know if you're not a sports fan,
this is going to bore the shit out of you.
But these are all the fucking places
I've been to that now no longer exist.
Uh, the Boston Garden, Sullivan
Stadium, a Yankee Stadium, Shea Stadium,
veteran's stadium, three rivers
stadium, soon to be no longer there.
Joe Louis Arena,
the RFCA slash Hoosier dome.
I saw Peyton manning there.
Uh,
I saw a game it original soldier field.
Got a picture and then this fucking
asshole stole my God damn camera.
I would say at a picture of
me. And uh, when I went to, um,
a green bay packers, that game
was a, um, was a preseason game.
They played the browns bread five or
it was still there. The verse, he says,
I can't count that one cause it's
pretty seasoned. But the reality is,
is he just wants me to book,
you know,
book a Gig like the skyline
cafe and go to a packers game,
which of course I will,
I'll do all right.
Continuing on county stadium to
the target center, the Metro Dome,
the Edward Jones Dome,
which is still there,
but the Saint Louis Rams don't
play them anymore. Texas stadium,
the Astrodome mcnichols Arena Mile
High Stadium, Sun Devil Stadium,
that still exists. But I saw the Arizona
cardinals versus the Patriots there.
QUALCOMM stadium still exist, but the
fucking charges aren't there anymore. Uh,
I also saw that the,
um,
San Diego Padres there and I went there
with and watch Mark McGuire take batting
practice the year.
Uh,
he broke Roger Maris his record and I
saw him hitting number 27 to 28 there,
uh, Edison field before
they redid it. Um, La,
the La sports arena that's still there,
but I saw, um, who did I see there?
I saw the clippers there.
I saw the clip is there and biggie smalls
was in the crowd and four days later
he was dead. Swear to
God. Uh, the La Forum,
um,
I saw fucking a young Kobe
Bryant and just left the,
uh,
magic shack with del Harris is a coach.
I want to say Dennis Rodman was on
that team. I went to candlestick park,
sat out in right field and saw,
uh,
a early on he head getting bigger
Barry bonds key arena for a Seattle
Supersonics game with a rookie
year. Kevin Durant. And then,
uh, the kingdom. I saw
young Ken Griffey Jr.
I sat right out in center field
bleachers and as far as I know, oh,
you know what else, the,
uh, the Montreal forum,
I can't believe I forgot that
I saw the mantra in 1989.
I went up there and March and I saw I,
uh,
Canadians versus the fucking,
Minnesota North Stars
with Patrick one net.
Okay.
I of course, rooted for the North
Stars and they of course lost. Um,
so whatever.
That's,
that's the dumb bullshit that I
do when I'm out here on the road.
And now I can add the a, after
tonight, do Carolina and, uh,
I want to thank the comedy
zone for hooking us up,
mmm.
With some sort of Duke booster that gave
us those tickets. And I was surprised.
Of course it came to the game.
I came to the game,
came to the show last night and left
without saying hello, which was like,
at least go to thank the guy.
So if he's listening or she's listening,
whatever the fuck it is a, I
mean, the tickets. Thank you
so much. Uh, and with that,
let's listen to me try to read out
loud as I practice for an award.
Show the nominees for the
best kiss in a fucking well,
we about an octopus. All right. Uh,
Luke, Craig, everybody give me the loop.
Speaking of Biggie smalls,
rest his soul.
Be The envy of your friends and get
your 100% exclusive crates@lukerate.com
slash burr and enter my code
burpee you are are just saved.
$3 off on any new subscription.
Crush that first sentence.
Wait until I tell you
about February's crate.
It is very put together
and I fucked that one up.
Copy points mentioned at
least three times times spot.
Fuck. Does that mean on a quest for
epic gear, housewares and collectibles?
Loot crate has it the best surprises.
You know it was coming.
Loot crate offers an epic focus texted me.
Oh, all right. Um, if you're more
of a testicle fashion, Easter,
I'm going to bomb at this fucking thing.
Then try Lou.
Where monthly wearables and accessories
with coke classics and your favorite
franchises.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger loop.
We've loop a duel with loot crate DX.
Want to geek out your pet?
Try loop pets. The Wa do.
I Dunno who this is.
Like this shit is insane.
He's going to buy all these
crazy tee-shirts about
fucking movies and put them
all over any living thing.
If you're a,
if you got a Goldfish tria lucky
loot fish, scuba wear. All right.
Get ready to get him or her a
little aqua man fucking outfit.
Get ready for the pop culture theme.
February is pop culture theme build.
We create as an awesome and exclusive
items from the most put together
franchises.
This February experience.
Iconic items from mighty morphin. I
don't know what that is. Power ranges.
Batman,
lego dimensions and Tetris,
including as always our
monthly tee shirt and Penn.
Go to Luke [inaudible] dot com slash burr
and enter my code burns say $3 off any
new subscription today.
MMM.
Holy Shit.
This is perfect for the award.
Show the black Tux looking great for a
wedding or a special event has never been
easier with the black tux.com I'm fucking
doing this with high quality rental
suits. Then I got to measure myself.
Don't, I don't know. Fuck did you do that?
You gotta Use Your Chin,
right?
Trying to get ahold of drink down with
the high quality rental suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux is giving guys a
new way to rent and get this.
The black Tux offers free home.
Try on so you can see the fit and feel
the quality on your suit months before
your event. Well, I got days the
best part, it's complimentary.
Done online.
No trips to the tuck shop required are
right and he want it does it twice.
I saw it the fucking first time.
The Black Tux stop come you
lets you create your loop,
your look, your Luke Craig.
You'll look or choose from tons of styles,
stylistic selected outfits
starting at just 95 bucks.
That's the kind of Tucks I'm looking for.
These suits have a modern fit and are
made from the from fine Italian wool,
itchy,
the highest quality on the rental market
and if you have any questions or issue,
their expert customer care team has
your back every step of the way.
After ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before the event.
That's a full two weeks to try it
on to make sure everything fits.
Anything's less than perfect.
The Black Tux will send you a
free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop the rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that to get started now?
Visit the Black Tux, stock comp slash
bar and experience a new way to rent.
That's the black tux.com/bar.
All right, I'm getting exhausted.
Just fucking reading blue apron.
Hey everybody,
not all ingredients are created equal men.
Fresh,
high quality ingredients
make a real difference.
So it's important to know
where your food comes from.
Talk about how it feels to cook for
yourself. Oh my God. First of all,
what I love most about it is I can do it
in the news. You know, it's my kitchen.
If I pulled the blinds, who gives a
shit? Right? You know, I put on an apron.
You know, it's Kinda like when you're
completely naked cooking with an apron on,
that's kind of like a,
that's the kitchen's version of chaps.
Um,
each meal comes with a step by step.
Easy to follow recipe card
and pre portioned agreements
and can be prepared in
40 minutes and left, uh,
less blue prince freshness.
Guarantee promises that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right.
Customize your recipes each week based
still on your fucking preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options
so you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment. So you
only get deliveries when you want them.
Check out this week's menu
and get your first, uh,
your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blue apron.com/
[inaudible] you will love how good it
feels and tastes to create an incredible,
incredible home cooked meals with blue
apron. So don't wait. The Blue Apron doc,
that's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook. I like those guys.
You know,
they giving you a healthy food and they
only make me say their website one time.
All right? Lastly, but certainly
not leastly, uh, distilled jeans.
A great jeans just don't
have to be complicated.
If you're not into crazy
stitching diamonds in embedded
studs, you're not alone.
You know it's funny,
you know what I'm about to come dad jeans
now guys who became dads and like the
last 10 years is those true religion
ones that add like that horse shoe
stitching on the fucking back.
I saw a couple of guys at the airport
wearing those and they had like kids and
shit and they're all faded, you know
the dumb white stitching down the side.
I didn't even buy those things.
Those things from from day one look
like some country singer Shit. Right?
Alright. Distill, pronounced
distilled a offers luxury,
great denim at an affordable price change
that would normally cost you hundreds
to still has just starting at 75 bucks.
You know what,
they sent me a pair and they
were really fucking Nice, uh,
that utilize the same fabrics and
factories in wash houses as the best known
brands and designers while skipping the
markups and the middlemen, the result.
Pure, unadulterated denim with real
retail without the retail run around.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com spelled d e s t l d m.com.
Uh, and see, um,
where minimalist designs
meets maximum comfort.
They guarantee the,
they'll ship them for free and give you
free items of return until you find the
perfect pair. I'll give
you free returns. Sorry.
This still has been featured in Forbes
Times at tech crunch as well as on denim
clad celebrities and Gq and vogue just
still is the only place in the u s you
can get this quality denim for this price.
You can find their amazing selections of
outerwear, leather jackets, tee shirts,
and more using the same principles of
high grade materials at low in cost.
Even celebrities are wearing just still.
MMM,
okay.
I got a pair of the name,
the gene style and the fit is perfect.
They did give me a pair of jeans. I don't
know what style it is and uh, yeah, they,
they,
they hugged my junk pretty nicely.
Distilled is your answer to elevate
style without elevated prices.
Just go to distilled.com/for right now
and get 10% off your first pair. That's d.
S t l d.com/for for 10% off right now.
That the five letters,
d e s t l d.com/burr.
All right,
let's start.
That's Delta, Sierra, tango,
Lima, Delta. All right,
let's get back to the top of the
page here and finish this out.
Um,
all right.
Has that been a half an hour? I have no
idea. I never know whenever I'm fucking
recording on just the garage
band thing here. So, uh,
we're going to go to the
game here tonight. Um,
I can't believe I'm going to see them
be this close to fucking coach k.
I know Duke's having a
tough time this year,
but coach k's back from
back surgery and um,
he did that thing where he,
uh,
I guess every once in a while I
get so disgusted with his team.
He doesn't let them wear any dupe.
Yeah.
Gear.
And he won't let him in the locker room
until they start playing at a fucking
level that the university is used to see.
You've got to love that old school
coaching. That made me look up like, um,
you know,
I was looking up all this stuff on coach
k and I didn't realize that when he was
in army he played for Bobby Knight.
I didn't know that he assisted
with Bobby Knight and all that.
And there's all these
great fucking pictures.
You got to see the way Bobby Knight is
dressed in 1979 in Puerto Rico when he
set the pan and games of course he
ended up getting arrested because he
allegedly slapped a cop
or something like that.
Yeah.
You want to talk about a guy that needs
to fucking meditate? Jesus Christ. Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I was watching all this stuff where's
coach sent me down this rabbit hole of
Bobby Knight stuff
and um,
you know,
my favorite clip of all the Bobby
Knight ones was when somebody secretly
recorded him cause I feel like that
was the real Bobby Knight is I thought
towards the end he kind of was,
was doing the Bobby Knight thing.
Like when he did that game face thing.
I think at that point he was just,
he started like hamming it up when he
didn't need to. But like when you listen,
that one where he's talking about the
Purdue game coming up and that he has an
eight and 10 record, um, I swear to God,
I'm going to start listening to that
speech before I go to the gym because I
actually listened to that thing and he's
talking about how he had to go to some
function and he goes,
I'm sitting down,
I'm tired to sit down with a fucking
eight and 10 record every fucking look.
I'm sick and fucking tired. Oh,
this isn't a fucking burrito.
Okay,
you guys get the fuck out there. Said some
of the, if you fucking lose to Purdue,
you put me in that fucking position. I
will fucking run you something until you,
I don't know, something about
puking or whatever. It's,
it's just such a great speech.
And in the end of it,
my natural reaction, I laughed and
just said, that's how it's done.
And, uh, I know we got a lot of criticism
for the stuff that he did, but, um,
I think a lot of that criticism came
from people that are not athletic.
We're never in a locker
room. And, um, you know,
they came from that hole,
they actually had bad experiences in
sports and listening to Bobby Knight Yell,
I think just brought all their sucking
in gym class memories back and,
um,
I dunno,
it's like there's this certain type of
person that is a fucking athlete and can
handle that and understands
what the fuck that is. And, uh,
I think if they don't
have a problem with it,
all these people who don't play sports
should just shut the fuck up about it
because you don't understand
what's going on. And, um, I mean,
Jesus Christ,
Bobby Knight won almost a thousand fucking
games and all his former players for
the most part love him. And, um,
and I always felt that kid that lasts
fucking incident that Bobby Knight had.
Um,
I thought that felt that kid was baiting
him cause Bobby Knight walked by and I
think the kids said,
what's up night? You know,
say that that's totally disrespectful
and night just had that fucking temper
zero to fucking 9,000. Um, but I,
I mean when I heard that story is like
that kid was being a fucking cunt. Um,
but you can't do that shit anymore.
At least during his heyday there
was no cell phone cameras, man.
He really would have gotten a lot of
trouble because they would have been
fucking video of that.
And I would have loved every second.
I would have loved every
second of watching him grab
some student by the fucking
throat who just did what's
up night guys walking around.
900 fucking wins. Some sophomore
comes by. That's come on.
Um, so anyways, yeah. So we're going
to be hitting that game tonight. Um,
if anybody knows a oh by the way, I have
to give a shout out man. I went to a,
um, this is my new thing now
and I'm on the road, you know,
cause I got my beautiful little daughter
up at home and I can't play drums as
much, you know, uh, knee is still lets me
rehearse and stuff like that. You know,
never rehearse like practice and
shit when uh, what I'm homeless
feed the kids up blood.
Um,
I haven't been able to
go to a, uh, you know,
the practice place that I go to
out in La as much as I would like.
So I'm like one, I'm on the road out
or look up these rehearsal spaces.
So I looked up this place when I was in
Charlotte, it's called the playground.
And um,
I went down,
shout out to Eddie z who runs it totally
fucking one of the coolest dudes I've
met. A lot of these rehearsal
spaces are just absolute shit.
The drum kits are old. Everything's
fucked up. Everything sounds like shit.
I went into this place, this place
was like a fucking FirstClass place.
He stopped me in the best
room that they had a,
at a discount price cause they were doing
construction on some other rooms that
he didn't want them, you know, disturb
me or whatever while I was playing,
I played for like fucking three hours.
Well,
I paid for three hours long
to get it to about, you know,
two hours and 20 minutes in my body was
like giving out on me and I just had the
best fucking time. And you know
what I loved when I went in there,
the snare drum was tuned to low and I was
able to tune it up to some pretty good.
And I used to not even remotely have a
game plan on how to tune up the snare.
And um, I was really
psyched about that. Uh,
but anyways,
this guy at z was saying he,
he actually used to be a roadie for
van Halen and he was on the 1984 tour,
the last phone with David Lee Roth and a,
then he did a couple with Sammy Hagar.
So he had all these fucking
really cool pictures,
just originals that he
took of like Sammy and, uh,
Eddie van Halen and David Lee Roth
was really fucking cool. And uh,
I had the best time and
like that's going to be on.
So what I'm to do when I'm on the road,
now that I'm,
I'm back building up the hour,
work in the comedy clubs
like the old days. Uh,
it had such a great time last night on
stage, uh, comedy zone. Do comedy zones,
one of the best fucking comedy
clubs up there. By the way,
if you can find the God damn thing,
he got to,
he walked in and there's like a cafeteria,
then a bar and there's, there's a sign.
This is comedy zone and nobody tells you.
You got to like ask like 20 people.
It's like you're feeling
your way through the dark.
Did finally go down those stairs that
go down there, but just the hallway,
there's the stage is set up.
Um,
it seems like every seat in
the house is a good seat. Um,
you know, I'm obviously, I've never
sat in the crowd out there, but uh,
just had the best time working
the shit out. I did two shows,
both shows I was able to do a little
over an hour just pasting together new
ideas that I have and then old bits that,
you know, never made it on to specials.
And I'm just, I don't
know. This is, this is,
you wouldn't think so,
but this is one of my favorite times
of doing stand up is just letting
everything else go and just trying to
figure out like what the new shit's going
to be. You know, I'm reading
newspapers, I'm writing shit down.
Anything that I can
throw against the wall.
Last night I was on stage talking about
how fucking human beings are edible,
like, and everyone was
like, what the fuck?
And that'd be something
that I would abandoned,
but I had no material and I
just kept going with it. And um,
should, I dunno, it just takes
me back to my early days.
Um, I was stand up when, uh,
because you, your skills,
like if you don't have the material,
it just complete your skills
to completely diminish,
even though you have the poise and,
and the,
the skillset because you've
been doing it that long,
but it's just completed just from imagine
a band if they had to like just work
at workshops, some rifts in front of a
fucking crowd without like rehearsing.
That's the greatest thing about the art
of standup comedy is that you can't,
you can't go to rehearsal space and get
the shit together and then fucking like
you have to
second you like coming up with
riffs in front of the fucking crowd.
Um, and it's, uh, yeah, it's fucking work.
It's absolute work. But, um, I
dunno. I'm a fucking lunatic,
so I totally enjoy this part of it. So
anyways, that is the podcast. Once again,
thanks to whoever it is that
owns these two seats, um,
whoever that is getting
in with the comedy zone,
you have free tickets to any comedy
show that I ever do for life,
front row, whatever the fuck you want,
forgiven given up these tickets. Um,
Jan, thank you enough. This is
going to be amazing. So, um,
we're on our way up to a Durham
and I was just out there,
so I know a couple of good
spots to eat at. So, uh,
we're going to have a good
time. All right. That's the
podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
[inaudible] and I will talk to you a,
I'll talk to you on Monday. I'll let
you know about the game. All right.
Uh,
Ooh.
Yeah.
Hey, what's up? This is bill bar and
a, this is the Monday morning podcast.
I just did a 50 minute podcast.
I tried to save it and uh,
didn't once again this week.
Talk for a fucking hour
evidently to nobody. Um,
I'm going to have to buy some sort of
device so I can save him so I can try and
put them back up. I don't
know what to tell Ya, but uh,
I don't even know if this
one's going to record.
I don't know if I'm going too long.
I don't even know who the
fuck I'm supposed to call.
Who the fuck do I call sound like I call
this number on anybody you can talk to
kicks up. You know, typical
of how we're living.
You know, I was on the fucking
airplane flying out to Boston, right?
I'm on the airplane and for some reason
they always have the fucking intercom's
turned all the way up to 10, right? Hello.
Is My goddamn ear drums out? So I
say the lady, she walks by, I go,
is there any way you can turn the
thing down? He's like, Nah, I die.
There's nothing we can do. The fuck do
you mean there's nothing you can do?
You can call up there, you can
fucking turn it down. But it would,
they be installed an intercom system
on 10 with no fucking volume,
whatever. Fuck this technology shit.
I got to figure out.
Somebody sent me an email about
something that I can record into.
I'm going to try to find that.
I guess I got to go out and buy it,
but I apologize.
Um,
I'm gonna try to do one again
tomorrow or something like that. Uh,
oh Jesus. It was such a great podcast.
God dammit. All right. Whatever.
I'm going to try it tomorrow.
So all 14 are you hanging in there?
I'm going to do a podcast
tomorrow. Alright. Take it easy.
[inaudible] Hey,
what's up?
Um, I don't know what the fuck is
wrong with his cheek cast thing,
but I have figured out
how to save my podcast.
All I had to do was press number two
for some reason I wasn't hearing that,
you know,
I dunno she was saying it or whatever.
The computer with the fucking
female voice has been saying it,
but I don't know what's
going on with this thing.
It seems anytime I record
something for longer than,
I dunno what a fucking go through,
but I know how to save him.
So all I'm saying is from here on out,
um,
I won't lose any more podcasts,
but I'm going to do a podcast tomorrow
and I'm going to save the thing and
hopefully I can publish it.
All right.
Thank you for your patience and God
bless the United States of America.
So [inaudible]
hey, what's going on? It's bill. It
is the Monday morning. My podcast,
I'm going to said poured
the Monday morning podcast,
we'll Guyland six 18
on a fucking Wednesday.
And I learned how to save these
podcasts and he go, this is the podcast.
This is it. I'm doing one
take. I don't give a fuck.
I've already done it three times and
I'm running a red light and I made it.
Good deal. Good deal. Oh Hey
you guys, you guys got cameras,
you've got cameras where you're at.
You know,
you run a red light and they
take your fucking picture
and then for some reason you have
to pay the fucking ticket. Um,
I got a way around it.
I got away around it that I've learned.
Somebody told me all you gotta
do when you run the red light,
he's gotta be in the center.
You know, if there's two lanes,
just be in the middle,
have half your car in one lane after car
and the other lane and it doesn't get
your full license plate or your
full face and you throw it.
Granted,
I haven't tried that yet,
but I heard you can do
that also is another way.
When I got my car out here in
Los [inaudible]. Evidently,
evidently there's so many
fucking people out here that, uh,
that, you know, it takes, I swear to God,
it took like four weeks or six weeks
for me to get my license plates,
something ridiculous.
So basically I drove around
for well over a month
with just the name of the
dealership where I bought my car,
act on both the front and the back.
And one day as luck would have it,
I was like going to the airport and I ran
a fucking red and they took my picture
and I flipped out and I was
like, ah, fuck. You know,
that's me flipping out that fuck
sake. I stink at acting. That's good.
Bill, could you raise the stakes you
want to? I really did. I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
This is fucking punk shit.
That's what I really did. But I
didn't want to yell like that. And um,
but basically all they had was a picture
of the deal is, and my stupid a face,
so I never got the ticket.
Why am I admitting to this?
Can they use this in a court of law?
Come and get me say so anyways,
I'm driving down the street and I don't
have my laptop with me so I don't have
your questions,
but God knows I read them enough times
that I can actually remember him once.
So here's the first question
somebody asked me, hey bill,
what kind of drum kit do you have and
where you're having a band and if so,
do you have any good band stories?
All right.
I have a late seventies Slingerland
five ply the fireflies shells and nobody
wants, everybody wants to three
ply shells from the late sixties,
early seventies to get that great tone.
Whatever the fuck they're talking about.
Well fortunately I'm a comedian
so I don't give a fuck. I'll take,
I'll take the extra two plies. And uh,
basically yeah, they're all Bonham sizes.
14 by 24 bass drum.
I had a 13 [inaudible] 14 and
then an 18 inch floor Tom.
So years later I bought
the 16 inch floor Tom.
And recently I had another bass drum
cause I was listening to the Primus and I
was like,
I want to play like Tim Alexander even
though I already had a double pedal.
I'm like,
I'm going to add another base drum pedal.
Cause that guy from slayer said it's
not the same unless you have the fucking
both of them.
So I went out and I bought another bass
drum and I should have realized the fact
that I suck with the double pedal,
that they added a second bass drum.
All it was going to do was just take up
more room and it wouldn't make me any
better a drummer, but I did it.
So, uh, yeah, that's what I played.
I got an old Slingerland kit and
have I ever been in a band? No,
I was never in a band.
I just had a fucking,
I did the drums were at my house
so everybody came over to jam man.
And we sucked.
Which is why everybody who ever
came over and now has a real job.
Um, yeah, that's it. I
don't have any rock star.
I don't even need to fucking
Dan stories other than that.
We stunk the usual shit.
And the next question somebody
asked me was, what the fuck was,
the question
was some question about I guess late
at night they got these new economy
dentures, something like that.
That's what the person asked me.
Have you seen these economy dentures?
What the fuck is this? And uh,
it's actually a really
interesting question because
I used to work in a dental
office and I know a little
something about dentures. Huh?
We're going to meet peeling off another
layer of the onion as Madonna says.
You know, she actually had the
balls to say that one time.
She doesn't have any balls. God
knows. We've all seen her Twat, um,
that she actually had the nerve to say
that when she did yet another totally
planned out. You know, look, I
can dress like a whore this way.
Nice fucking parking job.
You fucking idiot.
Fuck. I swear to God, man.
People just, you know,
people cannot fucking drive out
here in la. They really can't.
Like a lot of people don't know that.
All they talk about is the traffic.
Who are good. It's good if you could so
fucking bad man. Well, you know what,
when it clears up the driving get, then
people can actually drive the, their uh,
I have established it's
before, you know, they fucking,
they suck at driving out here.
Look at that homeless guy.
There's a homeless guy out here, I swear
to God, he looks like George Clinton, um,
from parliament. Anybody. So anyways,
you're asking me what
these economy dentures are.
I'm going to guess that they
are a one size fits all denture,
which really fucking bizarre.
And I bet um,
on the upper it has some sort of form
fitting thing that will fit to your
palate. It's horrific because when you get
a denture, you're actually supposed to,
you know, this impressions,
you pour up a model. You know,
if they took out some teeth,
they tried to get the teeth
to look like your other teeth.
So you don't freak people out.
Like one day you look like a witch and
the next day you come walking in and look
like Guy Smiley.
You know,
I used to work in a dental office.
I actually am certified to take x rays.
I can take impressions.
The upper impression was the worst.
I'd always get some. I'm just going to
let you know that I'm a gagger. I gag.
Really?
Why don't you just brush you fucking
teeth so I don't have to worry about you
throwing up on the fucking
left sleeve of my, uh,
like what, what do you
call it? The doctor robe.
The doctor coat or whatever.
Yeah.
I used to take the impressions
and people used to always gag
when you do the top. And if you
hang in there another eight seconds,
and then they always have, then
they'd always say, yeah, God,
I fucking hate the dentists. Really? Well,
why don't you brush your fucking teeth?
You idiot. You know? I
guess I do the same thing.
I ain't going to the gym,
but God knows I'm going to go order
a fucking pizza right now. Jesus,
I'm going to move. So yeah,
that's what I would guess.
So basically after you
took the impressions,
if you want to know the whole fucking
process and the person's going every five
seconds, if they don't puke on you,
you actually have a good impression.
Then you'd take it into the little lab
and then you take out a little green cup.
That rubber Green Cup,
that's all I remember. Things
can only be mixed in that.
I never took a chemistry class,
so I don't know why it couldn't
be just a plastic bowl,
but it was always those rubber things.
And then you'd mix it up
and then you'd pour it
into the fucking impression and then
you'd stick it on this little vibrating
thing,
trying to get all the bubbles out of it.
And it was nothing fucking worse if you
didn't get all the bubbles out of it.
And then I swear to God,
the bubble would always be right where
that person's tooth was and you'd fuck up
the whole impression. And then he'd
have to go in there and be like,
we gotta do it again.
I'd have to deal with that again.
So I would guess that what
they're doing is, is they, uh,
they're skipping that whole step.
I don't know what they do. If,
if you take a whole pack of juicy fruit
and you chew it up and then, you know,
form it to the top of your mouth and
then you mail that in and they make a
denture out of that. I have no
fucking idea. But that's really,
that's really a scary thing. It's
a really scary thing, you know?
That's the kind of Shit
I wish people focused on.
Like everybody keeps talking about
that fucking broad with the eight kids.
Can you believe it? I mean, that's
so irresponsible. Who gives a fuck?
People talking about all the
money she's going to cost us.
She's going to cost the swat a couple
million. You know? What about the,
so you know, the fucking bankers,
three quarters of $1 trillion,
nobody gives a fuck about that. Some chick
squirts eight babies out of her twat.
It's going to cost us, you know,
one half of 1% compared to what?
These fucking constant who
stole a trillion dollars
and then gave themselves $30
million bonuses. Nobody gives
a shit about that. You know,
some chicks squirts out fucking eight
babies and all of a sudden no one can stop
looking at it. You know why? Because it
has a face. You know what she looks like?
That's the thing.
That's the genius of the bankers.
Nobody knows what a bank or it looks like.
I don't even know what the fuck my teller
looks like. I go to the Goddamn ATM
because I worked nights. Um, all right,
what else?
What else could I do on this podcast?
This is going to be a short podcast.
I'm doing a podcast until I get home
and that's going to be it because I'm
exhausted with these fucking
podcast. All right? It's insane.
The amount of podcasts that I've done
this fucking week and to no avail.
You know,
it reminds me of listening to somebody
talking about who the fuck was it
recorded with like a Ray Charles.
You do like nine,
9,000 takes of Georgia on my mind and
by the end of it you wanted to make them
deaf too. You know, that's why I feel
like right now with these fucking podcast.
So,
um,
I guess the last thing that I have to do
is I'm stuck in traffic waiting to make
my left hand turn to come
home to order a pizza. Uh,
is that got announce the winner of the uh,
the submissions for the
original a proctologist I
went to the proctologist joke,
I got to omit man. They were all
strong and everybody seemed to like,
there's sort of an even amount of people
like in every one of them except for
one. So basically I think I'm going
to pass out like a three or four DVDs.
You know, you know what? Everybody's
a winner except for the one guy,
the one guy who meandered for 20 minutes
about having the chicks Katie mashed in
the mammogram is the only one that
didn't get any votes. Everybody else,
the guy with the potato salad
line got a lot of votes.
The dude who freaked me out and
got a bunch of votes and uh,
the dude who did the,
uh, had the great angle.
I thought this was the
most original angle of,
of the gay guy bragging that he's
dating approch cologists you know,
if you didn't listen to that podcast,
he was saying,
it's kind of like if you know one of your,
one of your buddies started dating
a gymnast, you know, and then,
then all your buddies would be jealous.
Like Jesus Christ.
I bet she can do some freaky shit.
You know,
he can bend her every which way.
He was saying gay guys would do that.
I bet they'd get jealous if you started
dating a proctologist and they'd all be
sitting around going to hi. I bet he
really knows his way around it. Ass.
Thank you. That was the hacky gay guy
voice. I don't know if you guys noticed,
but my chick's voice is basically the
gay guy voice just done at a whisper.
If you ever want to get that
impression down, instead of going,
hi fellows,
I just go,
hey, what's going on? This is
it's relationship coaching.
Exact same thing.
I make complete fucking no talent and a,
anyways,
I'm in my garage right now.
So this podcast is over. I
know it was a quick one.
I know. It was a quick one. All right.
It's a little 12 minute. It's an EDP.
All right. Like guns n roses life.
That's what it's like. All right. Stop.
I didn't drop the n word even though
there was a half black Obama guitarist in
my group.
How fucking drugged up with slash that
day where he fucking coach signed on that
one. Anyways, I want to thank
everybody who came out to the, uh,
my shows back in Boston.
Uh,
the comedy connection at
the Wilbur Theater and out
in Chicopee, Massachusetts.
I had an, I had a great time coming back
there and a bunch of friends, family,
former babysitter from the 70 showed up.
It was a,
it was an unbelievable weekend. And
uh, then I went out to chickopee,
Massachusetts.
That shows sold out as well and a bunch
of drunks and I made my way through it.
And, uh, then I went back
to my fancy hotel in Boston.
I owe today Philemon Yawn.
The maid had left classical
music on the clock radio.
Trying to remember how this went down.
That's why I walked into my
hotel room that, you know, the turn down
service, I don't know what that means.
They fold your sheets back and they give
you a mint and she left classical music
claim on my clock radio.
I ordered the filet minion,
a little mashed potatoes,
a glass of red wine.
And I sat there and ate it.
And it was one of the most
loneliest experiences I've
ever had in my life to the
point I actually had to call Robert Kelly
and tell him in the moment how lonely
I was. The stakes suck too. I actually,
it was such a bad steak. I actually
didn't even consider putting a one on it.
I went straight to catch up. That's how
bad it was. And I don't put anything on,
you shouldn't put anything on a steak.
They should just tastes delicious.
And this thing was so fucking,
I ordered it medium rare and it was gray
all the way through and it was tough.
Like fucking shoe leather.
That Mozzarella. Um,
anybody know what's that one from anybody?
I'll give you five seconds to tough like
fucking shoe leather. That Mozzarella,
I only know one other fucking person.
We have a new,
that reference rubber brought it
up and he owns Gotham comedy club.
It was a Eric Roberts
in the pope of Greenwich Village.
Tough like fucking shoe leather
that moves around. Anyway,
the fucking steak stunk and I
actually put ketchup on it. I like it.
Literally take it tasted like fucking
hamburger cause hamburger tastes great,
but you know what I mean? Any chefs
out there? You never put ketchup.
Okay, let's do overrated. Underrated.
You know what's fucking overrated?
A one steak sauce. I
don't even get it. It, it,
it's just,
it sucks.
I am in a garage right now talking to
myself basically about fucking a one steak
sauce. Who gives a fuck? I'm
done with this podcast. Next
week you're going to get,
you're going to get a double album
out of me. All right? I promise you.
But this week you get in the eep.
All right.
Thank you to everybody who came out
to the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts and all you fucking meth
heads and drugs who came up to the Hooky
loud and chickopee Massachusetts.
And uh, my next Gig,
my next upcoming Gig, I am going
to be at wise guys in Ogden, Utah.
I believe it's Saturday night,
the, uh, February 21st. So,
uh, please come out to see me, man.
I've never done a club up that way.
I've only done colleges and a why don't
you come along and bring your 18 fucking
wives or whatever the hell it
is you Mormons do out there.
And uh,
you know,
I figure you're a cool Mormon if
you're actually listening to the stove,
you know,
come out to the show and uh,
congratulations to the
Lakers in the Cavaliers, man.
You guys look like you're
going to be playing,
you're just playing a hungry or game
playing a fucking hungry or game.
But I have to, I have to say this
before I sign off. I really think that,
uh,
the reason why I can't stand the fucking
NBA is unlike any other sports like
that, that sport, the officials
control the outcome of the game.
Like I've never seen.
It's like,
it always like the Celtics
Lakers was a fucking great game.
And then down to the end they just
kept blowing the whistle on both sides.
I'm not being a cry baby here. Lakers
won fair and square. But I'm just saying,
you know, sometimes they should just
put the fucking whistle away, you know,
just let them fucking play. And they
did that. And the Cavaliers game,
it's like you've got these two juggernauts
going head to fucking head and then
this little fat, he flown his whistle.
Now all the action stops and then,
you know, you know, hey, stop
pushing him. That's ridiculous. Okay,
let's let them shoot uncontested.
It's the most,
it's the biggest fucking buzz kill to
the end of any game I've ever seen.
You know, and I love how God
there's been a referee that was,
has been busted for having mob ties in
the fucking NBA and I'm supposed to act
like that's the only guy
that was just one bad apple,
you know, I think, I dunno.
What do you guys think?
There's my question for you this week.
Out of all the four major sports,
which referee do you think if you bought
them could really influence the outs?
The at the uh,
the outcome of the game.
I didn't have to go and be a cause.
It's so easy to get a guy out of the game.
You just keep calling files in football,
you know?
Do you want how many you took?
Throw a guy out of the game.
You've got to wait til he,
you know,
kick somebody in the balls and spits
in the face. And I don't know what,
look at me babbling and it'd
be not literally the light
and my garage went out.
I got to get out of the car.
All right guys. That's it.
I'm going to save this podcast
so you're going to hear it.
What's,
I don't know how to fucking uploading.
It's been a brutal week. All right, good.
All
right.
Fuck list bill.
I wake up at my girlfriend's house.
She leaves to work. I can't find
my socks. She says I have some.
She says I have some
just use mine and leaves.
I wake up later and I looked for the
sock drawer. Top drawer. Right. Um,
and I find this list with about 20 to
30 names on it and my name is near the
bottom. Oh No. Some have
check marks on them,
et cetera.
I asked her about it and
while she's initially upset
it turns out to be her fuck
list.
Yeah.
Wow. I don't have a fight.
I have a list in my head.
She actually made a fucking list.
Okay.
Dude,
you coined a phrase.
Okay.
She said she made it after we got together
with some friends drunk one night.
She then admitted to being
somewhat of a whore. Her words,
not mine before we met,
but assures me that she
hasn't done anything since
she met me with anyone else.
I do believe her,
but I totally blew up on her.
And we haven't been
talking for a few days.
I also look a bit creepy as to why
I went through her door drawer.
It was in an envelope. Yeah.
You know what it is? Yeah.
You kind of look creepy,
but she would've done that to you.
You know women call it snooping when
we do it. It's fucking creepy. Anyways,
he goes, I need some help here on this
one. Do I apologize? She already has.
Do I just say fuck it and forget about it?
What's knee his take on it?
God dammit.
You know what?
I'm going to have to ask her.
Take on that one.
I'm not going to have it on this
podcast. When I, when I go home,
I fly home tomorrow,
I'll try to have an
epilogue to this podcast,
um, or maybe tack it onto
to the following weeks.
That is a great question
because I don't trust this girl.
Okay.
You know that when, when a
girl, is that fucking free?
Yeah.
All right. And I know girls are getting
mad. Why? Why can't we be as free as you?
I'll tell you why you can't, because
you don't have to work at getting laid.
Okay? I can be sexually liberated.
I still have to go out to the bar.
I got to do a fucking tap dance.
Okay.
You know, like me getting laid, it's,
it's like somebody on fucking,
uh,
American idol trying to get that ticket
to Vegas. You know? That's what it's like,
is it for most guys anyways,
to get laid.
Even if you get good at it, it's,
it's like fucking, you know?
Okay.
It's, it's, it's not hot, but you
guys, anytime you want to fuck,
okay,
you can fuck. Look at that. Golden
Knights came up with a back out.
I didn't know Hosea. I put my hand
and I wasn't ready. 44 year old guy.
I'm sitting there, the boop,
boop, I can't even fucking talk.
Um,
so that's what I would be worried about.
Okay.
She said she's a bit of a whore.
Like,
okay,
I don't know if that's a good thing or
a bad thing or if like, uh, I don't,
I don't know about that one.
And she sat down and she made a list.
Jesus Christ, 20 to 30
names. Now this is the thing,
I don't know how old
she is. All right. 20.
You know, for a girl, 20 to 30 names,
I don't think is even that bad.
The fact that she, well I dunno,
but it might be even worse because,
okay.
They,
they,
yeah,
I'm not honest about their number. They
do the exact opposite of what we do. Guys.
We exaggerate our numbers.
They dial them fucking back like,
okay,
like women's,
how many guys have you been with?
Numbers is like when they put out how many
people are unemployed in this country,
you know, they try to keep that number
fucking down. It's the same thing. Uh,
uh,
fuck list.
I mean, uh, I, I don't know
how I'd ever get past that.
You sat around with your friends,
are your friends all whores,
you know, and it's not like they just
sat there going, oh yeah, you know,
I fucking, you know, Bobby,
fill up fucking Dakota Tornado
ever fucking modern name.
Um, Range Rover, whatever.
Fucking people called kids and boys now.
Um,
and then, you know, there's
checks next to them of,
of like what she did with
them or how good the deck was.
And, uh, I,
I don't know if that's one of those things
that they all fucking do and you just
unfortunately peek behind the
curtain and you should let it go.
I have no experience with
something like that. Um, oh,
this would have been a great nia question.
I have to do this with her and
get into a fucking giant argument,
but then I run the risk of
possibly getting a fucking
preview of her fuck list,
which I don't want to know about.
I don't want to know if, I mean,
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't give a fuck at my age.
I'll give you a clean good. Okay.
What do I think you will fucking
God damn bubble. I hope you banged
enough guys and learned how to fuck.
I really do cause I don't need some fish
in bed, you know, just laying there.
Haman fucked a lot of people.
Great. Isn't that Greg?
Do you want a pilot who
hasn't flown a lot of planes?
You know there's give and take. Okay. You
got a girl hasn't fucked a lot of guys,
ed,
you know?
Okay.
She sucks at Dick.
Like she's eating green beans.
That's the tradeoff yet.
Oh, ah, dude, that sucks.
Okay.
That really sucks for you.
Why were you going to wear one of her
socks to work though? You know, with,
with a little fucking Chris
Everett ball hanging off the back.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].